zehn Tage sind es noch bis Russlands
Krieg in der Ukraine ein ganzes Jahr
lang geht und offenbar will Russland vor
diesem Jahrestag Fakten schaffen denn
wir haben Berichte aus dem Osten und aus
dem Süden der Ukraine das Russlands
Truppen jetzt versuchen überall
vorzustoßen also neue Truppen die bisher
nicht da waren die also mobil gemacht
wurden die aus verschiedenen
Landesteilen dort hingeschleppt wurden
und wir wissen dass diese Truppen jetzt
entlang der gesamten Front im Osten hier
versuchen vorzustoßen wir hatten ja in
den letzten Tagen und Monaten eigentlich
bloß diese dieses Gebiet hier wo die
Wagner Söldener eben versucht haben
bachmut und Soldaten dass also ein
Gebiet hier im Zentrum der Front wir
haben aber in den letzten Tagen eben
auch die Situation dass sie russische
Armee hier zwischen kremina und Liman
Vorstoß hier von uns wird doofe in Hans
nach westenvorsteht stößt aktuell auch
wieder versucht guckt jansk einzunehmen
was er im letzten Jahr befreit wurde von
der ukrainischen Armee und eben diese
mega Offensive auch hier unten in Wuhle
da dort ist es die
Marine Infanterie der russischen Armee
aus Fernost die dort versucht voran zu
stürmen und 130 Fahrzeuge darunter 36
Panzer letzten zwei Wochen verloren hat
und wir haben natürlich auch weitere
offensiven hier rund um donetz wo man
versuchte in afdiefgar nördlich der
Stadt und in
Marlinger südlich der Stadt vorzustoßen
das heißt die russische Armee versucht
tatsächlich den Druck auf immer stärker
ja aufzubauen und zu verstärken eben
offenbar zum Jahrestag hin das Problem
der russischen Armee ist bisher reicht
es überhaupt nicht das heißt was sie
bisher einsetzen ist eben etwas worauf
die Ukraine vorbereitet war das sind
Panzer es sind Bodentruppen es ist eben
nichts Außergewöhnliches es ist keine
neue Front und sie stoßen überall in
starke Stellung rein der ukrainischen
Armee und wie das aussieht wenn so ein
russischer Vorstoß dort zum Erliegen
kommt das können wir hier sehen das sind
neue Aufnahmen der ukrainischen Armee
aus der Gegend von wurde da und wir
sehen hier ein russischen t 80 Panzer
ein sehr moderner Panzer der im vorstößt
aber ja wir sehen es hier völlig
überhastet ohne über ohne Infanterie
ohne dass Leute sicherstellen dass er in
ein sicheres Gebiet sich bewegt nach
vorne stößt wir sehen hier hinten seine
Spuren und wir sehen das vor ihm
überhaupt gar keine Spuren sind ja das
heißt da war noch niemand vor ihm wir
sehen über die Einschläge natürlich und
was jetzt gleich passiert ist dass
dieser Panzer in ein Minenfeld fährt der
ukrainischen Armee und dann eben
gestoppt wird wir sehen jetzt hier den
Moment wo er die Mine getroffen hat und
was gleich passiert ist eigentlich noch
viel unglaublicher wir können uns das
erstmal angucken die Leute versuchen
jetzt rauszukommen das heißt die
Besatzung hat es überlebt hier sehen wir
jetzt hier oben die Besatzung versucht
jetzt diesen Panzer zu verlassen und was
jetzt passiert ist eigentlich ja man
kann es sich gar nicht vorstellen wir
gucken uns das ganze mal an
hier haben wir also diesen liegen
gebliebenen Panzer dessen Besatzung
bereits geflüchtet ist weil sie eben
dort ja von einer Mine getroffen wurden
wir haben vor ihm wieder wie wir gerade
eben sehen keine weiteren panzerspuren
das heißt das ist ein ungesicherter
Bereich der eben völlig gefährlich ist
für Panzer und was haben wir hier ein
weiteren T80 Panzer der auch den
gleichen Weg kommt und jetzt und das ist
eigentlich unglaublich versucht an
seinem Kameraden hier vorbei zu fahren
und das endet natürlich in Desaster wir
schauen uns das mal an die Panzer kommt
also versucht an seinem anderen Panzer
vorbei zu fahren und fährt auf eine
weitere Mine und explodiert dort auch
der gedreht jetzt völlig außer Kontrolle
und fährt hier in den Wald rein und
bleibt dann dort stecken das also die
Angriffsversuche der russischen Armee
könnte das Ganze noch mal in im
Durchlauf ansehen die man sich einfach
gar nicht vorstellen kann ist sei denn
es gibt eben Befehle völlig blinde
Befehle aus dem Kreml und aus dem
russischen Verteidigungsministerium die
ihm sagen ihr müsst ihr vorstoßen ihr
müsst diese Stadt oder diesen Ort oder
diese Stellung erobern komme Wolle und
auch gegen jede Logik und gegen jede
militärische Rationalität also hier
nochmal der Moment wo der zweite Panzer
versucht vorbei zu fahren auf die
nächste Biene fährt und beide Panzer
sind verloren so gehen innerhalb von
zwei Wochen eben 36 Panzer verloren
allein an einer Front nicht weil die
Ukraine hier so unglaublich gut
vorbereitet werden sondern weil sie
einfach machen was man eben macht um
eine Front zu sichern und die Russen
eben voll reinfahren
wir wollen uns aber auch die Situation
in bachmut ansehen und das sind
Aufnahmen hier ganz neue aus bachmut die
erinnern ein bisschen an Ego-Shooter
Videospiel ist es aber nicht sondern wir
haben hier tatsächlich eine Helmkamera
eines ukrainischen Soldaten einer
Spezialeinheit Omega das sieht man auch
da unten in der Ecke das Symbol das
Omega und dieser Soldat geht eben
zusammen mit seinen Kameraden hier von
Straße zu Straße und versucht die Russen
zu vertreiben aus aus Bach Mut aus eben
dieser Großstadt 70 Einwohner ehemals wo
aber mittlerweile wir zeigen das gleich
mal auf der Karte aus allen möglichen
Richtungen eben die Russen einfallen in
diese Stadt das also die Wohngebiete von
bachmut noch nicht die Wohngebiete im
Zentrum die haben auch 10-15 gestöckige
Häuser sondern die Wohngebiete im Norden
und Süden der Stadt wo eben die Russen
sich in diesen ja
einfamilienhausanlagen eben weiter
versuchen vorzukämpfen und das auch
relativ erfolgreich schaffen die
ukrainische Armee also versucht mit
diesen Spezialeinheiten wir sehen das an
diesen grünen Bändern um den Helm herum
das ist Ukrainer sind versucht mit den
Spezialeinheiten dort reinzugehen und
versucht tatsächlich jeden einzelnen
Russen aus diesen Gebieten wieder zu
vertreiben oder zu töten das gelingt
ihnen mit mäßigem Erfolg muss man sagen
machen Mut selber ist weiter unter
ukrainischer Kontrolle aber am Norden
und Süden der Stadt rücken die Russen
weiter vor und haben da auch erhebliche
gewendet wenn auch sehr langsam wir
gucken uns das ganze mal auf der Karte
an
und sehen hier noch mal eben bachmut und
was wir eben gesagt haben ist dass das
Zentrum der Stadt kann man so markieren
etwa dass das Zentrum der Stadt das ist
weiter absolut unter ukrainischer
Kontrolle da gibt es Hochhäuser da gibt
es auch eben ja die ganze Infrastruktur
Theater und so weiter da gibt es keine
Kämpfe aber hier im Süden hier im Osten
und im gesamten Norden haben wir eben
russische Vorstöße und die Ukrainer
versuchen immer wieder die
zurückzudringen und wir haben bereits
gestern gesagt dass die Russen nicht nur
versuchen bachmut selbst zu erobern
sondern eben auch dran vorbeizukommen
also hier und hier eben eine Art Kessel
zu schlagen um eben ja der ukrainischen
Armee die in der Stadt sehr gut
aufgestellt dass das unmöglich zu machen
sie weiter zu verteidigen und wir haben
auch dort naja Aufnahmen aus krasser ein
vor Ort ungefähr fünf Kilometer nördlich
vom bachmut dort haben die Gruppe Wagner
gestern eine ein weiteres werkerobert
man sieht das hier ein Werk in dem
Materialien zum Mauerbau hergestellt
werden hier also die Gruppe W oder eben
diese russischen säulenarmee die diesen
Ort erobert hat und die eben dort weiter
vorstößt und das Problem an dieser
Fabrik ist auch wir sehen uns hier
nochmal ganz groß das ist ein relativ
hohes Gebäude ungefähr acht Stockwerke
hoch und von da aus haben wir natürlich
ein sehr guten Überblick und können eben
auch ihre Scharfschützen beispielsweise
da oben postieren und können dann
dementsprechend auch den Norden von
bachmut von dort aus eben sehr gut
überwachen ein weiteres Problem also für
die ukrainische Armee in bachmut zu
allerletzt wollen wir uns ansehen die
Situation wieder mit der westlichen
Verstärkung denn dort ist es so dass uns
neue Bilder erreicht haben und zwar aus
Polen wer will da die wenn man so genau
anguckt schon Aufsehen erregend sind
denn das ist tatsächlich die ukrainische
Armee die erstmals auf dem Leopard 2
trainiert ist der Leopard 2 A4 also eine
relativ alte Version aus den 80er Jahren
und wir sehen hier auf der rechten Seite
einen polnischen Offizier ähm sieht man
auch an seinem mit seinem Brett an an
seinem an seinem ja Mütze wenn man so
möchte und hier sehen wir zwei
ukrainische Panzerfahrer die also zum
ersten Mal offenbar in einem Leopard 2
sitzen und sich dementsprechend auch
freuen auf sich freuen dass sie jetzt
gefilmt werden und ja eben zur
Ausbildung jetzt ungefähr sechs Wochen
lang in Polen angekommen sind um eben
dort in Leopard 2 zu lernen oder wie man
ihn fährt das gleiche gilt auch für
Deutschland auch dort haben wir aktuell
die ersten Ukraine die angekommen sind
es gibt noch keine Aufnahmen davon aber
am Ende können wir uns mal angucken was
hier gelernt wird nämlich erstmal
offenbar das Schießen ja wir haben ja
also eine eine Range wenn man so will wo
eben hier sehen wir das mehrere
Leoparden 2 A4 stehen hier hin da ist
ein M113 der das offenbar beobachtet und
wir sehen das eben erstmal nicht das
Fahren geübt wird und dass das zusammen
agieren aber in diesem Moment zumindest
hier wird das Schießen geübt wir sehen
viele Leopard die hier stehen
nebeneinander und eben auf einer Range
gucken ja wie treffe ich mein Ziel in
das ist dann die Frage in zwei drei vier
Kilometer Entfernung das Lernen also
gerade die Ukraine ein Teil ihrer
Ausbildung die fünf bis sechs Wochen
etwa gehen soll in Polen bevor sie dann
mit den Panzern zurück in die Ukraine
gehen um dort hoffentlich endlich ihr
Land wieder zu befreien
[Musik]